Tuesday was the birthday of
Geek Squad employee of the year
Edward Snowden, one of the few
people in trouble with the law
for a leak
that isn't public urination.
Snowden's infamous leak led to
one of the biggest revelations
about the NSA's surveillance
tactics. I would like you
to come up with
some lesser-known top secret
government revelations
in 60 seconds. And begin. Steve.
Joe Biden is from Kenya.
Yeah, no one ever asked.
Points. Eli.
Ramsay Bolton is actually
based on Donald Trump.
All right, points.
Spike.
Bernie Sanders has a giant dick.
Points. Points.
Uh, Eli.
The NSA beats off
to your Snapchats.
All right, points. Steve.
Sometimes if you
pee white into a lady
it makes a baby.
Oh, Jesus...
Christ.
I didn't think you could
gross anyone out more
after (bleep) with the sock,
but well (bleep) done.
Points. Spike.
Hans Solo dies.
All right, points. Spike.
It doesn't matter who wins
the election, we're all (bleep).
Eli.
Bernie Sanders is actually
one of the old guys
from the Muppets.
All right, points. Steve.
Some dude name Remy
actually let the dogs out.
All right. Points.
I'm glad we solved that. Eli.
Lemonade is really about
Bill and Hillary.
Aw. That's nice.
Spike.
The Harlem Globetrotters'
games are fixed.
-HARDWICK: What?
-Yup, it's true.
Now, that's the oldest
reference we have...
That is probably the oldest
reference we have at all.